two big stories this week speedos are
known for it's not the it's not its
global warming jarred love a bit of
global warming
yeah son come early brilliant sorry
[Music]
can we start with youtubers this week I
don't want to start with the bad bits JJ
and Logan but added again
Twitter beef do you want to watch this I
don't know what the [__] that is but
let's watch chic porn the opinion we've
all been waiting for the LAN port
deserves the very much eju with the
champion of YouTube in my opinion long's
gonna [__] not our case I drill the
first just sort of got those lazy you
know like a dogs with your cats with you
and they're just like Logan first
ng simple as for to be fair I kind of
agree with them on the log and then Jake
I agree with the opinion it's just that
I already held the opinion it's not an
opinion which differs to common opinion
he's basically saying whatever I was
thinking who's the biggest [__] on
YouTube I would say ksi why would you
say that he's just like to me he's
literal like literal trash literal trash
he's not literal yeah he's literally not
trash see that guy there yeah yeah
total Sidon what brought ashore said
that the logan paul podcast guys were
weirdos he responded to hurry and was
like what [__] let's do a fight I've
met him before he seems like a nice guy
don't fight hurry he's probably the
strongest of all the lads in the sidemen
hurry like if he actually trained
untrained yeah the strongest easy
genetics honest yeah so I think that
wouldn't work out too well for him
absolutely
so stop challenging Harry believe me
pick any of them other than harm
basically and the energy user cuz
getting a bit fiddly probably leave him
alone
hashtag muscle March so then Morgan and
JJ stop going at it
yeah on Twitter it's or logon starts I
bet money psi is gonna try and skirt the
rematch not money something else he's
lost like 20 grand on the UFC fights we
probably should stop betting JJ says you
had your chance you blew it besides your
brother has popped and we're more than
you you ain't got the juice no more on
the chump he deserves a shot
I need a revenge my broom daddy still
alive dad geez yeah he's a lot yeah JJ
abyss he says that Jake's about to pass
Logan and sobs how awkward which is true
Cloyd
you and TF Yui I don't who that guy is
but he's a youtuber stole your next girl
log in response this was a harsh one
your family abandoned you on Christmas
you're a [__] so it isn't going well
Logan then does a video on a Scion don't
skirt the rematch I already I feel like
you're gonna try to don't do it unless
you scared should we look at the views
because JJ is accusing Logan's views
have gone down it's all point in Logan
vs. JJ was because of where they were in
the pecking order on YouTube subscribers
eighteen point eight million well yeah
he's still doing two million two million
two million one point five to 0.1
million so Jess gained in hard log and
does have a podcast check check got
Logan's podcast I mean he's got a guest
book oh wow yeah I mean he's really put
money that he's in back into the channel
not just into his own pocket for his own
gain that is incredible he's done there
because it the number one podcast in the
world when we do a podcast top drawer
top drawer unbeatable yeah he puts out a
lot of podcasts sure quality not
quantity that's all I'm saying
right when I do a part it's it's special
my native ass it's like deep
conversations yeah a deep-sea diver I've
never mentioned that much are going deep
with these people how many of your
guests cried this is a percentage to
prey on alright how many is a percentage
cry in terms of quality of podcast right
under way I am yeah in number sort of
number eight nine Joran's probably
doubling Logan Paul's number at least at
least at least to be seen Alex Jones
what do you want to see cuz I want to
see you Logan case I want to see the
ring I think I would like to see the
rematch because it was such a good fight
the first time he's a delivered they put
on a great fight and also they love both
had extra training who can be better by
the time the rematch comes on and
because normally when a rematch ends
like that the second one always ends
differently I would like to see JJ
versus Logan and then JJ versus J if he
wanted to do that I think it would be
[__] entertaining as all I'm saying
but I want to see the rematch first I
want to know who's the best Jake said on
the podcast that he thought if he'd
fought JJ the night Oh Logan did
absolutely would have beaten JJ no no no
I'm just gonna say that as a boxing
expert nope
you struggle to get rid of dead G and
and edgy wasn't the the boxer JG was he
wasn't the size JG was he hasn't got the
power I'm not saying that Jake can never
be good enough to compete with Jay Jay
or beat GG because if he put training in
anything's possible but that night not
in my opinion no I'm interested to see
it happen if it happens I'm interested
what other stuff is happening
unfortunately modei back to the [__]
pedo shoes in it I am surprised that you
agreed to do it why are you sitting down
with us today I'm very tired of all of
the last you know I'm just I'm just
tired
what are the lies that you're hearing
that disturb your mouth oh my god I'm
innocent
that's one the biggest lies I've ever
heard I'm sick of people to fish they
would all tell everyone I'm as guilty as
a [__] I'm sick of people
defending me because I was on the the
spacejam soundtrack just because I was a
sound check to your childhood doesn't
mean I'm a command alright cuz I'm
saying I believe I can fly don't mean I
wanna fly in your daughter's underwear
yeah sorry oh it's you fault what I know
have you done anything that you regret
have you done anything wrong lots of
things wrong when it comes to women that
I apologize but I apologize in those
relationships at the time I was in the
relationships they broken any laws when
it comes to women because it's laughs
I'm worried guard my TV beside me the
hell if he hears this [__] he broken any
laws everybody say something bad about
me nobody said nothing good they was
describing Lucifer no they were
describing off Holly I pretty sure when
I heard that definitely where Oh kevie
usual abuse man it was the devil you're
saying everything they said in that
documentary about you is not true they
are Lionel Messi that's what a five year
old says in class video channel I know
me well you find out in the documentary
that he did struggle with like English
that's why it lyrics is so simple remix
to ignition hot and fresh out the
kitchen
wow I had a relationship in the past it
just didn't work out she can come and
say the same exact thing
are you blaming this on social media I'm
talking about the power of social media
if
one or two women come forward and try
and get a [__] you know you're
[__] David Beckham and you're like
yeah [__] it I'll write a book about
this then then maybe they're just trying
to make money of them there's too much
on this guy wait oh he's talking [__]
yes is interested in because this one
sometimes when people say no but they're
not their head so nobody is allowed to
be mad at me and be scorned and allow me
so they're lying on you that's your
explanation they're lying on you
absolutely yeah absolutely
have you ever slept with anyone underage
no how the align on you absolutely this
really reminds me of a child to be in
core and it's a very big theatrical not
taking account of what you've done
deny deny deny scream and cry until you
get what you want now you've got
remember this man has been a very
successful famous guy from very early on
but you don't have to grow up and you're
not forced to grow up in the real world
and play the adult rules and you can
just be a [__] [__] and get away
with it you continue those all behavior
patterns and this is to me like an
eight-year-old stomping and screaming
really way saying is my bit my work and
my fame afford me to be able to do this
and he's he's banking on us going oh my
god
she handled this very well yeah she's
very good very good is like a mum with a
toddler she holding her place like that
shows him to be even more childish yeah
that was a one moment that spoke to me a
little bit as a as a man sometimes even
monsters can meet you feel a bit sorry
for them sometimes and when he brought
his kids up I thought well the fact that
you're thinking of your kids and not
just yourself at least is and I know
we're not allowed to see anything good
about our colony but to me it was it was
one of the only things that I thought
you said that actually had some hot in
there true to make the count point to
that of course someone who's done
something so terrible would pick on the
thing that makes people motional maybe
is smaller than I'm giving credit for in
bringing that when you are Kelly why
would you have to hold girls against
their will and all of that shit's you
know you don't have to do although I do
that for me it's the underage stuff that
I find it's it's the it's less the
treatment of the people it's more the
predatory behavior around it from the
documentary he was like that from a very
early age it was always in him and even
his brother in prison was a year
ya know surprised yeah and a big problem
the way this is covered is there are
generally two camps are Kelly's innocent
or we're damning are Kelly what we
haven't really gotten into and I'd
imagine what's happening behind the
scenes is a lot of people going how can
we stop this happening again how do we
work out what happened in our Kelly's
mind got him to this point what we're
seeing with Arkady and then Michael
Jackson is up brings oh so important and
when someone's had a terrible upbringing
and then get a lot of money and fame
it's like vodka and cocaine it's a
nightmare rather than explaining his
innocence he just says it doesn't make
sense exactly once again very childish
very young in the mind this guy he just
thought he could do what he wants and
get away with it I think as well he's
having trouble reconciling the person
that he is because he never saw himself
that way and we all like to paint
ourselves in the best-laid we're seeing
this version of him but we've also seen
the version of him that's in a nightclub
drunk off of power from an actual drink
and and grinding on [__] girls and
you seen the guy use do you know me
moving on to Michael Jackson we've all
watched a bit of the neverland maybe
I've watched it all we're gonna do a
podcast on it because it's like
something they're really chewing while
we're talking about Michael there's a 10
undeniable facts about Michael Jackson's
sexual abuse allegations not all this
stuff was in the documentary in such a
succinctly there was no dispute age 34
Michael Jackson slept more than 30
nights in a row in the same bed as the
kid that is in the documentary it is
when you see it in black and white there
that you think wow that's unusual so far
five boys Michael Jackson shared beds
with said they that they were abused by
him there's other kids who see him
holding hands with who haven't come
forward but you think it
hoppin Michael Jackson suffer from a
skin discoloration disease the other
things called vitiligo su-ure chandler
drew a picture of the markings on the
underside of Jackson's penis his
drawings were sealed in an envelope
months later investigations photographed
Jackson's genitalia the photograph
matched if a kid cannot guess this why I
start getting frustrated is because of
how much his funds defend him and we can
cover this more in the podcast but like
how the [__] are you gonna justify that
in your [__] head
usually when I ask someone do you
believe Michael Jackson is innocent or
killed when they say is innocent
obviously they don't know it's because
they haven't watched any of this sort of
stuff but John that guy yeah fair enough
you haven't watched it if you watch it
and then don't believe then I'm just
like don't you have and believe yeah
honestly I'm sick of covering the sort
of [__] every week on true newzik this
is supposed to be where we have a laugh
and it's [__] morbid it's ball this
is a little scene on Twitter so it was
interesting okay
if you love me to see one a day as a
young man so I finally start on today
what but Michael you know you're a 44
year old man now what do you get out of
this what do you get out of it the most
loving thing to do is to share your beer
with someone you mean your anything bad
yeah after we watch a documentary that
just seems even more [__] weird but
also how on the money Bashir was and
everyone was going you're trying to take
his name through the Margy [__]
do you remember what it was like but
that guy was outcast by so many people
because they weren't you've tried he's a
hit piece on Michael Jackson or this
[__] do we give Bashir him a series
of he was challenging someone who was
eminently powerful Spector pressin
yeah I think we needed a moment to make
make light of this theory yeah that's
great horrible
HBO documentary about me he's filled
with lies and eating I would never hurt
children
I love just good in English that's
always to grow me
people of color [__]
oh my god yes I'm a good pedophile -
I've got the whole amusement park you
can talk yeah oh my god Wow it's rapey
is the dark [__] it's so true you're
getting posted it now as I [__] me that
is growling
but couple of months ago Mia Khalifa
nearly appeared on the true Giada
podcast I was then notified by
management we weren't alone asked about
upon courier - clearly is ashamed of it
I then rightly decided well [__] that
then these guys didn't get the memo it's
not every day you get to have someone on
who is an avid sports fan who was also
at one point in time the number one
ranked adult film star on pornhub
so she's supporting her team the
Washington Capitals against our team the
Tampa Bay Lightning and that I don't
know where well I guess out of somewhere
one of those damn pucks makes a beeline
for Mia Khalifa's boob and then it
ruptures her implant do I have that
right so far Mia first of all I was in
the adult industry for three months so
you need to [__] fat sex before you
asked me to call into your City radio
station goodbye yeah she definitely
doesn't want to be called punks I think
we can confirm that now absolutely Elden
I was in the adult industry for actually
an extended period of time every month
can I just say an enormous amount of
dick was consumed in that three months I
mean sometimes two at one time right
I just insane little reality check for
Mia Khalifa you took a lot of dick on
camera right he wouldn't be where you
are today
without doing that that's what all the
men watched and order to give a [__]
about you you try to sweep it under the
carpet like I never took a lot of that
you did we watched it sometimes two on
one go really did you watch it yes right
even a good point she was the one who
did the a [__] thing yeah she wrote
religious clothing your [__] self
appalls so that'll do it
yeah but she's wanting to be respected
as a pundit am I actually hearing this
right yeah I'm not even respect that as
a PUD no and you've not consumed nearly
as much dick definitely no you've
consumed a lot of her consuming a lot of
penis but you've never put a penis in it
now I've never stopped trying to [__]
cover it of there are thousands of
videos of you doing it on the Internet I
don't care what bubble you want to live
in but it's [__] my name is Tracey
kiss and you may have seen before
I did a video called the semen facial
tutorial the idea behind that was to use
natural organic clean and healthy
ingredients in order to promote beauty
yeah all you listen woman when she says
organic if your boyfriend's going out on
the weekend eating a kabob coming home
that is not a grass-fed camera do you
know what I mean part of the syma facial
then led me on to looking into the
benefits of digesting semen [__] off
take your shitty snake oil and [__] on
imagine you're in the gym right you've
got your personal trainer with you it's
your first session you just paid what 50
to 60 pounds I love it though you feel
the burn feel the burn with it and
you're going she's going come on nine
ten now let's just take a second let's
discuss your diet what sort of things
you know nobody really you've just
finished but it's time for a protein
shake yeah husband health [__] this
mornin oh you've run a family business
well I suppose so the kids hold the
beaker and daddy just you know deposit
into it who can we not bring kids into a
fourth and 1 teaspoon of semen contains
over 200 proteins several helpful bits
means minerals including vitamin C
calcium chloride citric acid
fructose lactic acid magnesium nitrogen
phosphorus potassium sodium
vitamin b12 and zinc do you hear that
ladies fantastic the benefits are there
we're just giving you the information if
you and your boyfriend or significant
other want to meet them
to true Jordi semen calm where you can
buy your flask of genuine true Geordie
semen
do you want to swallow gallons and
gallons if this man's come well now's
your time I can't watch it so this was a
clip from a little amateur wrestling
match where you see the little poor lad
whose left leg trapped underneath his
body probably bad knee ligament damage
skull smashed what all parents doing
with the kids generally that's that's my
annoyance from this animus like rather
they've played for yeah that's not the
way to encourage kids to like sports if
you're a parent and your kid can destroy
people like that then maybe get him
where competition is available what the
[__] is this yes it's brexit bull sorry
this is some sort of local town thing so
I think the goal of this is to get the
ball somewhere in the town sort of one
half the town versus in the other half
of the town that's it's very Simpsons
just just watch right these guys are
diving in the middle to get the ball
these are hard men Oh
I mean the game is [__] no no no get out
look at him punching like real real hits
on each other this is a riot with a ball
in the middle this is just a rock
believe the bull made its way inside
this house and then they were trying to
get it back out and the men were like
defending the door so they're trying to
get themselves up and over you've caught
up see that you can't even fight
properly at that point no and you're
standing on people you can't fight nice
you know money how many pubs are boarded
up here yeah how many I mean even the
bank in this town border literally this
is it all filled with money it's filled
Brian with semen there's too many people
so I need to nominate like your best 20
yeah you know I mean at the moment
you've nominated the town yeah nice
crime is not you yeah I grew up in the
80s and there was knife crime back then
between blacks and whites and now it's
definitely between young black men in
small tiny communities and it's
affecting everyone we all look stupid
you look even more stupid if you've got
a knife or you know someone that's got
tell him to stab themselves but I was
watching this capacity I was like where
are you going with this but then he
makes a really good point right now
trust me because you just gonna stab
your future if you go to stab someone
else metaphor good story
that's my doing actually starve yourself
everyone yeah we're a lot of people turn
into their friends with knives and going
it just Elvis stab yourself there you
course over here talk win and then pull
out these young people don't look up to
us ma'am we need to just vocalize this
send a message out and put the knives
down it's done alright it's done we
don't need to be killing ourselves we
have so much more we can offer and
you're gonna kill your future you're
gonna kill someone else's future and
it's done
he just said was probably one of the
coolest beep so and that's why he got to
drag the formulary car and you didn't
know yeah we were to formulate the event
and Idris Elba was there it's very rare
I'm ever in a room and look at a man and
think you're handsome yeah that was one
of the few times yeah he was in the same
room as us and I thought myself I can
Haley want to ask him for a podcast yeah
and then I just thought cuz he was with
his family I didn't want to be that guy
getting to the point sorry finally yeah
knife crime bad so if you are a young
lad out there because it is mainly young
men let's be honest thinking about doing
anything with a knife [__] don't ya
all right and don't stab yourself not
because he's right it just [__] your
whole future up and it hurts everyone
around you everyone around the victim's
family it's a stupid dumb selfish thing
to do
I believe in reincarnation so you know
we'll figure it out
you think yeah you think you've already
been reincarnated you think this is how
many lifetimes you think you've been
reincarnated already oh I think I'm
still a novice probably three that could
have been a woman maybe native woman you
know or something nothing too dark you
know but I think maybe Laotian or
Polynesian maybe I could see because
sometimes I smile and I feel like
there's like the hands of like uh this
is gonna seem crazy but the hands of
like an Asian person kind of holding the
ends of my smile up from the inside of
me so he this might surprise you right
he had a huge drug problem I'm not
saying that that's why he talks like
this but definitely now the guy is funny
but he's also mad yeah do you ever feel
that you could have been something in a
past life
I've been told I've been reincarnated by
a couple of people really yeah if we are
in a cyclical thing with life where we
come back and we come back as different
people maybe different creatures animals
whatever I like to think that the people
that you're with in each iteration
you're also with but in different roles
the next play right my dad had a friend
by the way who said that they were
brother and sister in a previous life
that's a very sarcastic man it did not
go down well with her what did you say
basically along the lines of I'd hate to
be related to you okay what would you
like to be reincarnated as everyone but
like a person or an animal or whatever
just anything don't say to aerogan
definitely not no offense sir Joey's got
a cool life but I've done the podcast
thing now I want to do something else
next time yeah absolutely
woman know right women have it hard just
I think being rich from the get-go
having the word I hope to being rich
takes a lot of time I'd rather just
experience it from like a team have all
the spiritual things you could have
chosen you chose being rich from the
get-go like all these spoiled little
[__] rich kids right I wish I could be
one of them right just
it must be great for what million or
work that's that would be a lie phrase
really [__] me no work charcoal
toothpaste
we need a watch yeah we need the [__]
box yes clean gel I sort of want to know
what that is LED showerhead boot
organizers video technique is literally
he goes channel each other absolutely
I'm just gonna say it the guy shaved his
head but left sideburns
oh god I love that I love my dog I would
love to see a dog review a channel like
where the dog just all the reviews if
it's a buy right hoorah
yeah not a bipolar down I'm saving you a
channel there someone out there make it
you can always enjoy Cheddar's this
there's nothing wrong nothing offensive
or anything about each other
nothing offensive about Cheddar's offend
you
well I'm glad these thoughts bringing a
different flavors because the original
was just getting a little bit boring
funny thing is though nothing he said so
far if I disagree with no no he's on
point it's always a good time to
jettison that he's milled correct he's
got all the energy values and the fast
and the saturated cover always and all
that crap on the back I really don't
care about this is snack I'm not
bothered smell very nice taste how you
can hint go the hint of chili coming you
just be surprised if anybody seen my
last video with the doodle yeah he bout
to help me fingers off so what I've done
I'm being careful
gently Wow
we need the court of previous one we
lost among the fingers I'm talking this
way opiate this might be we're here too
son there's a way of training your dog
not to do that lots of things oh yeah
absolutely and it's not by saying a
human word gently like hoping that the
dog has full contact English language
totally sadly all you put the catalogue
on tape you want a doctor tell us t it's
called super clean it needs to clean
your keyboards I was going to use it to
clean the air vent on me man English
Prolog is not absent a [__] and below so
much nebulous information and I would
love a pipe with him oh yeah he's a
total or I'd sit and just talk [__]
spend the whole night with a more in the
whole evening a beer garden you don't
really want all do yeah yeah that's
exactly a mouse no I'll take the buses
always taking back bar you know I'm a
Konami guess what y'all seen the tits on
that don't tell wife about this but
bloody L seen the bar made tonight yeah
[__] hell
yeah why are they done not what is it
that a dirty keyboard he has got that
yeah you're watching Mia Khalifa right
oh wow I want to see what this looks
like mister yeah yeah that is pretty
good though yeah here we get before keys
no no you did it their own way around I
hope you've enjoyed getting to know this
guy blue van man if you do like him head
over to his channel hit subscribe
because he only got twenty four hundred
subscribers yeah will seems like a nice
guy
blue van man go to so yeah hopefully
you've enjoyed that's it's it's getting
a bit depressing for me talking about I
think next week no matter unless there's
some huge revelation which let's be
honest it probably will be I hope not we
won't have to mention off Kelly or
Michael Jackson again because it's still
my [__] heading we will have to at
some point though yeah okay thanks for
watching nor guys if you haven't already
subscribe let's see what the channels up
YouTube channel now one point five
million twenty three thousand nine
hundred and sixty eight subscribers at
the time of this video it's it's slowed
down faster one point five I've got
video but I don't care I've got still
going up there yes generally generally
going to put sort of more about the
content these days yeah hopefully as
I've enjoyed it let us know if you have
because a lot of the time it's just
people start complaining in the comments
and the ones who have enjoyed it tend to
just watch it me like yeah like that hit
the like was you don't leave a comment
leave a comment out where the [__]
if you can that would be great wow thank
gosh check out where the [__] see
you bye bye